طيب كيف تظهر هذه السيطره السياسيه
والاقتصاديه للحرس او السطو اذا اردنا ان
نقول من هم الجنرالات الذين يبدون مؤثرين
اكثر من غيرهم في احداث القمر
ولكنه يختلف عن اغلب المنظمات العسكريه
الاخرى
فلديه قياده غير ورسمه شبكنا غير رسميه
عنده وهذه الشبكه
سامسونج
يا شبكه غير ورسميه ومجموعه من
الجنرال على الحاليين والمتقاعدين من
الحرس الثوري وكل واحد منهم مسؤول عن جانب
من امبراطوريه الحرس التوريد بعضها هؤلاء
الجنرالات انخرطوا في اداره الاعمال
الاقتصاديه واخرون
التجسس ونشاطات السياسيه هذه مجموعه صغيره
نسبيا بين 20 الى 30 شخصا وهم الذين
يتخذون القرارات المعقده جدا نيابه عن
الحرس الثوريه
بان سيد
يجب ان يبقى هو في قمه هذا الهرم وربما
يقبلون بان النظامي همم
حتى يجمع تستمر بعد خامنئي ولكنها سيفعلون
ان يكون هنالك خليفه
السيد الخامنئي الذي شخص يمكن يسيطر عليه
بخلاف خامنئي وهو خاض بها لحرس الثوري في
الحرس الثوري
يحتفظ بهذه الواجهه المدنيه في اعلى هرم
السلطه في ايران ولكنه في الواقع هم
انفسهم الذين يتخذون القرارات
وبعض العلماء الذين كرؤائي دوله مناصيرنا
السياسيين الذين انتخبونا في المكتب
وبالتاليف عن القرارات الاستراتيجيه
سيتخذها على الحرس الثوري
والموارد الاقتصاديه للدوله هم ايضا او هي
ايضا ستوزع من قبل الحرس الثوري